so for some reason the trump campaign
continues to think that it's a good idea
to send people like eric trump and his
wife lara trump out to do interviews
despite being completely unprepared
and unqualified to be doing them in
favor of
donald trump's reelection campaign last
week we had this interview that eric
trump did with abc's jonathan carl
it went horribly wrong and then this
weekend we had an interview on cnn with
jake tapper
interviewing eric trump's wife lara
trump
and if you're even at all human you
almost start to feel bad for her you
know some of us do have this empathy
response
because of how horribly wrong this went
we did learn
over the last four years tens of
millions of americans have no empathy
response some of us still do
um let's look at some clips of this jake
tapper mentions
the town hall questioning related to
when did trump
last test negative for coronavirus is it
possible trump knew
at the first debate with joe biden that
he had the virus
and um lara trump just falls apart
president trump gave four different
answers in about 60 seconds
four different answers on whether or not
he had tested for coronavirus before the
first debate you were at the first
debate
yes or no did president trump test
negative
within 72 hours of that first debate as
was required by the debate rules
i assume the answer is yes i was not
physically there with him and i worked
for the youtuber
not in the white house i don't i i'm
giving you my honest answer i do not
know but i assume the answer
is that he tested negatives but you
don't know for i don't see why
you don't know for a fact why would the
president knowingly test positive and go
to a debate
i didn't say he did i'm just trying to
we've been trying to get a straight
answer for weeks as to when
he last tested negative and we haven't
gotten an answer i'm sure it is
okay but you don't know so here's the
question you're not giving a direct
answer
you you don't know i'll take you at your
word so of course at this point the most
likely scenario
is that trump either simply had no tests
before the debate remember they said on
the honor system
oh we're too late for the debate to test
us but we tested negative they either
didn't really test trump or they tested
and he came up positive
and they covered it up so that trump
could participate and lara trump asks
why would trump do that like why would
trump deceive anybody
the reasons range from relatively benign
like
trump just really wanted to go to the
debate to the sinister
like trump wanted to try to infect joe
biden i'm not alleging
either side but i'm telling you there's
a very broad range of
why trump would cover up or not be
tested for coronavirus the answers are
all bad none of them is good
uh this continues with lara trump lara
trump
then uh asked about
the chance of lock her up
that are frequent at donald trump's
rallies when trump
attacks gretchen whitmer gretchen
whitmer the democratic governor of
michigan
against whom a plot was uncovered to
kidnap and possibly assassinate her and
trump
has actually been ginning up more ire
against gretchen whitmer here is lara
trump with complete and total
what about ism like sometimes people
threaten me too hector tweeted last
night
i am the governor's deputy digital
director i see everything that is said
about and to her online
every single time the president does
this at a rally the violent rhetoric
towards her
immediately escalates on social media it
has to stop
it just has to don't you think that the
president should tone it down when
talking about people about whom there
have been literally
threats against their lives in this very
very
heightened time well gosh i would like
to show people my social media and the
threats against me the threats against
my children
uh when you have members of uh you know
the democrat
party uh coming out and telling people
get in their face
go harass them i mean this is not just
on one
joe biden but joe biden isn't saying
things like look
anything against you or your family or
your children
is horrible detestable and i condemn it
right now
and if there were any democratic
politicians that were you know
throwing fuel on the fire i would say
tone it down
why aren't you toning it down but i i
don't look at threats
based on what party are the recipients
and my question is
shouldn't everybody just tone it down
including your dad your father-in-law
well look this is he wasn't doing
anything i i don't think to provoke
people to
threaten this woman at all he was having
fun at a trump rally and quite frankly
there are bigger issues than this he was
just having fun
at a trump rally encouraging
more disdain which we know led to ire
and threats of violence and a plot to
kidnap a democratic public official
don't you get it guys
trump was having fun and that's what
matters when i watched this the first
time preparing it for you guys i i
was reminded of something my mom used to
say growing up whenever
i i would bug my little brother and just
have fun at his expense
um and i would say oh it's just fun it's
just funny
my mom would say and i remember it like
it was yesterday well it's because she
said it a week ago when i was bugging
him but
she said if both people aren't having
fun
it's not valid fun and i think that that
would absolutely apply
here then um lara trump was asked to
explain
why she appeared to publicly mock biden
for his
stuttering problem that he has had for a
very long time
and lara trump says no that wasn't
mocking him for stuttering it was
mocking him for cognitive decline i had
no idea that joe biden had a stutter
joe biden as we all know his work to
overcome a stutter
uh and one of the speakers at the
democratic convention was a young boy
who the vice president inspired named
braden harrington
uh take a listen it was really amazing
to hear that someone like me
became move about vice
president braden harrington a very brave
young boy
you made this comment earlier in the
campaign about joe biden let's take a
listen to that
every time he comes on stage or they
turn to him i'm like joe can you get it
out let's get the words out joe you kind
of feel bad for him
how do you think it makes little kids
with stutters feel when they see
you make a comment like that
uh first and foremost i had no idea
that joe biden ever suffered from a
stutter i think what we see on stage
with joe biden jake
is very clearly a cognitive decline
that's what i'm referring to it makes me
uncomfortable you have you are
no that's so amazing it's so amazing to
me that
and try and figure out an answer a
cognitive decline you're trying to tell
me that what i was suggesting
was i think that you were mocking his
stutter yeah i think you were mocking
his stutter and i think you have
absolutely no standing to diagnose
somebody's cognitive decline
i would think that somebody in the trump
family would be more sensitive
to people who do not have medical
licenses
diagnosing politicians from afar
plenty of people have diagnosed your
father from afar and i
i'm sure it offends you your
father-in-law from afar i'm sure it
offends you
you don't have any standing to say
noticing him what i'm saying
just uncomfortable as bad of a person as
lara trump is
it actually makes me a little
uncomfortable may i guess i don't have
that
sociopath gene that so many people have
to watch her implode so badly doesn't
this campaign have to stop sending her
out because these interviews
this can't be helping can it and the
real hypocrisy of course here is
trump is a mess as far as this type of
thing goes
trump glitches and malfunctions
constantly
yosemites he comes off of air force one
and can't find his limo wanders off has
to be brought back by the arm by secret
service
says where is rudy rudy sitting right in
front of him ulysses
s grant he wants to know the oranges of
an investigation he said people want
donald trump
who is she even to be talking about
cognitive decline
when she's supporting donald trump it
just
none of it makes any sense really really
bad
uh instance for lara trump and again i
think they've got to stop sending her
out but who am i to
suggest to them they think this helps
them then by all means continue doing it
i'm really excited that uh one of our
sponsors today
is helix sleep i sleep on a helix
mattress at home
i absolutely love it and that's why i
reached out to them about sponsoring the
david pakman show
buying a mattress in the past was always
a huge guessing game for me
i didn't know what i actually needed i
didn't know what i would like
but helix has a sleep quiz on their
website you tell them your body type
your sleeping position
your back pain issues you might have and
their
tool matched me with a mattress that is
perfect for me
it's cool enough at night it's the right
firmness
i generally just do way better sleeping
these days because of the mattress helix
was awarded
number one best overall mattress for the
last two years
by both gq and wired magazine it is well
deserved i can tell you first
hand every helix mattress comes with a
10 year warranty
you can try the mattress risk free for
100 nights
and they will even come pick it up at
your house if you don't love it
but i know you will all of my viewers
will get up to 200
off your order and you'll get two super
premium pillows
for free when you go to the link right
underneath this video